over here he's you know trying to manage
all the different things in his life and
you know be in a crazy family with a
hundred sisters and it's like it's wild
that was Kris Jenner back in 2016 giving
ET an update on her famously private son
Rob Kardashian it's never a dull moment
now a source is opening up to E.T with
the latest on Rob's life explaining that
while he'd love to find a great woman to
date he's instead focused on being a
good dad it's a really exciting time for
him and we give him I think more me you
know gives him advice and it's just been
a really fun time a source tells E.T Rob
is doing a lot better lately and adds
that while he's had a lot of dramatic
and difficult situations present
themselves in the last few years he's
now on his feet one of those situations
a 100 million dollar defamation lawsuit
filed against Rob and his family by his
ex and mother to his six-year-old
daughter dream Blac Chyna she is saying
that the Rob and China show
didn't get a second season because we
interfered with it
not because they weren't in a
relationship anymore
back in May a jury determined that no
monetary damages should be awarded to
the model ending the weeks-long case
now asaurus tells E.T Rob is feeling
much better than he was a few years back
adding that he is mentally emotionally
and physically balanced he's doing
really good and he is on his healthy
fitness journey which I'm so ecstatic
about you got to do the journey when
it's on your time and for you you can't
do it for anybody else and that's what's
important about Life
et's Source explains that Rob has been
taking care of himself and trying to
commit to a healthy lifestyle with the
help of his famous family
as for dream our source says when it
comes to being a dad Rob is hands on and
feels grateful to have his family
support with raising her we cannot touch
these elves guys
[Music]
of course Rob has opted to mostly stay
out of the public eye in recent years he
even skipped his sister Courtney's May
wedding in Italy to Travis Barker but he
has popped up on his sister's social
media from time to time why not like
last month when Kim shared this
throwback snap to honor their famous
Mama jar on her birthday that's Kim with
her sisters mom Grandma MJ and Rob
grinning ear to ear I don't know how
you're gonna top that and back in July
Rob took his daughter on vacay to
celebrate Coco's birthday
I know it's gonna be a good day oh yeah
Chloe shared that clip of her daughter
true Kim's daughter Chicago and dream
running around on their aunt Kylie's
private jet and that right there is a
tiny glimpse of Rob getting in on the
fun it's a beautiful thing so could love
be next for Rob our source says that
while he would love to find a great
woman he's just focused on being a good
dad hanging out with loved ones and
keeping things private
[Music]
foreign